I know that you are a guy that follows
politics relations always were we known
each other a long time yes what you want
you know talking about obama's
reelection how do you think obama's
doing well i think i think he's doing
fine because he can really really talk
and the republicans have a hard time
putting sentences together
look look look let me make my point
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh it's a feather in
america's cap that we went from w to
obama because you couldn't think of you
know w was like yeah and he was a plain
spoken man you know remember when he
famously said we got evildoers that's
kind of brilliant you know we got
evildoers i can't say anymore big day
they're doers and evil doers like to do
evil now Obama is incapable of being the
Harvard genius he is you know there are
people in the world who wish to do us
harm
you mean evil doers capisci fancy talk
but you could put him up I mean he's
he's just he's an intellectual I mean
Clinton had a great phrase remember that
one I feel your pain I do I feel your
pain
Obama would say something like when I
see that you're having a period of
discomfort I can experience confession
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now Regan we're going back in a little
time Ronald Reagan was present in the
1980s for all you kids remember when he
went to the Berlin Wall and he said he
was like he was very plain spoke mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall that was
very clear very dramatic mama would say
something like we believe that barriers
of any kind act as an obstruction to
people's good relationships what the
Oh Dragan would not either then I think
better than Ronald Reagan swearing
really what there's nothing greater in
all of comedy the only thing better goes
way back is Jimmy Stewart swearing oh
yeah oh my god oh I did that once on
Letterman and Dennis Miller after went
Carly in my entire life I wrote jokes
all day I'd never get a laugh as big as
Stewart going f-bomb how you doing
pretty good how are you doing
[Applause]
reach the depths of I can't believe it's
cool to swear on a test show I love TV I
know this will never air what they're
not gonna bleep it out are they oh
they'll never air now yeah this is go
like that this is being put in a bottle
and thrown in the ocean
[Laughter]